la pilotine va présenter ses deux
vénézuéliens la lcr a présenté ses deux
colombiens et puis on verra qu'est ce
que ça donne en tout cas sa voix semble
pas ma politique sportive et je me
répète ma politique ce mardi c'est pour
nous voir les jeunes suisses
martiniquais et puis comme je disais
nous venons de créer un pôle cyclisme
qu'on en train de restructurer pour des
jeunes martiniquais qu'un jour grâce à
aux cmt grâce à allah la djs et s est
aussi acajou donc c'est très bien on va
continuer dans cette direction de cette
dernière question l'a bien compris
président l'a fait en continu sur le
fond en octobre prochain aura prochain
rendez vous est ce que sur ce point là
vous vous sentez déjà un peu fébrile où
vous comptez contre attaqué sur ce point
pour le moment je n'en sais rien
j'attends la réaction des présidents de
clubs de martinique
ceux qui ont souhaité que nous puissions
mettre en place cette notion j'atteins
j'attends la réaction vous savoir quelle
direction point de boules à venir en
tout cas ce cyclisme ça ne me ressemble
pas ça va pas de cap de la politique
sportive et j'espère qu'il y aura une
réaction du côté des clubs qui font de
la formation vous savoir que faire
demain